what a time to be Andrew Scott hot
priests you also you've all seen back
yes now Lee I know you're a big fan hi
lovely bag and I have not confessed this
to my wife and we're really not I've
genuinely not confessed if she would
kill me but I feel like I should say
because it's he's here when it's
appropriate
I did the ultimate sin okay I got ahead
without telling my wife of the box set I
was pretending then when I was watching
it that I hadn't seen it because we'd
absolutely loved that second series but
I was texting she but why are you
watching this
I even said old it's not as good this
soon I had to say that's why I was
texting but at shadow would he seen it
because that Paloma that you've met
Andrew before yes and as you know I am
not shy of an awkward situation
no you direct and yes so I had to
confess to Andrew that I had a bit of
alone time with episode five
[Laughter]
thing that really upsets me is like
today is everyone else but me he's got
more of a chance without but you've had
a good time anybody who's got kids been
in a long-term relationship thank you
without my wife that was just to get
ahead that to you how what was your face
doing and really that she told me on the
red carpet of the BAFTAs she rose here
yes and she was like wow that's an
achievement yes that you don't think I'm
the only person and there's a lot of
people in the room looking at me like oh
my god but don't lie
I just wanted known that the fact that I
have my sofa steam-clean three weeks
[Applause]
just checking my the only one that's not
masturbating
[Music]
you